[Music]
hello my name is alfonso not
his so far bastille engineers
in paris there this episode do you speak the
cloud
we are going to work on the
network configuration of the fantastic knitting
unlike traditional environments
or in the beginnings in the
cloud you  don't need to
pull cables ripped out the servers all
this is done
programmatically this is called in sdr software
defined network on google cloud we
setup virtual private or
vpc network to live with cloud in
which  we define an
amorphous topology to ensure its bepc can
span multiple regions is
made up of mice that can
cross over no one within a
single region in google cloud a region
and a geographic location in
which google has a datacenter
ellison is  a section of a data center
that is self-sufficient in terms of electricity
and reason regions and ashes
are e  fundamental elements for the
architecture of the services in
availability but let us return to our
application is the compound of the two
instances of the web server apache which
hosts an application written in php
which connects to a database
mysql by swinging it genx distribute the
traffic coming from  of internet between
the two web frontends
our architecture is not yet
ideal it had a 1-1 point
while the load balancers fail
and it is vulnerable to load spikes
because regardless of incoming traffic we
don't have  that two web servers
to deal with it we will address this point
in the next episodes
today we will secure is the
original architecture on google cloud
to separate access well we will
create two reasons first the spell and
its tandem knit  gives in or will be deployed
our lobala then serves the smile on
knits a frontend where our web servers will be deployed
the two networks will be ratt  ached to the
western europe region 1 which is located in
belgium the nearest sum of 5
p.m. only our louvre-lens air must
be exposed on the internet on port 80
and 443 our web servers must
accept connections from puglia the load
balancer on  the same port by default a
virtual machine in google cloud
inaccessible from any other ip address so
we must configure the
rules of a firewall to allow these
bags it is to configure our
firewall relays we will use the
attacks in tag is a label  that
we add a virtual machine
to select it dances a fayolle rule
we could also use the
ip address of the virtual machine but
the use of tags is more intuitive
and often more flexible than the
configuration by ip address in the
configuration page of  our vm we
click on the edit earth button and
in the net section for taxes we
wave the tag of our choice
we will add  the web tag is lifted on
the virtual machine of the other alain
greenhouses and the web server tag on the
virtual machines of the web server
now that we have attacked our
machines we can create their own
firewall which will allow access to them
uteron of rules  the first to
allow sacks and from all
sources indicated with the side r 4
times its bones the 2d towards the
rear machine the tag well towards the second
to allow http https connections
to the machines tanguay web server
strip the machines of the burst rico
tandem yields  our service is now
accessible on the internet through the
launcher logo but the external ip address
between loadbalancer is not set by
default the sad recipe and external to
virtual machines are ephemeral they
can change
the machine restart time to  avoid these if
we have to make the ip address fixed this is
done in the
configuration settings of the virtual machine
you can also  reserve
ip addresses and the saas signed later at m
for more security we will
also activate the external ip addresses the
web server since they must not be
accessible which will tumble weary
now that our web server and
configure correctly to receive
traffic
we must  we turn to our
database this is a
sql cloud instance of mysql type there are three
ways to connect remotely
gesture cloud the first through the
private network the second through a
proxy while it is the third
through  the public ip address of
the sql core instance
we have chosen to connect
through the stas ip address this
option offers better security is
there you have fewer
connections claude sql is a
debate service giving oneself entirely  managed we do
n't have to worry about
the administration of the service you and the
virtual machine
hosting it besides we don't have access to the
ma  virtual china it is managed by
google and deploying them in a jacket
is managed by google to be able to
connect to our claude sql instance
through the private network it will be necessary to
connect the two bpc
that of the project containing the
web servers and those managed by google which
contains our barcelonian
to do this in the
configuration page of our instance claude
sql we click on connection
check the box to activate access by
ip internat
I am quite proud of vpc entry
click on to loket in connect and
degrade
those  -ci will reserve a place ip address
for our instances that sql for more
security we will deactivate access to
our childhood club is what she lives at
the public address
this operation will take a few minutes
now that we have
configured access us  can find the
internet ip address between them will give themselves to
fit into this birth claude
schell the command says cloud sql instant
six lists
the resum  ltat will be the list of instances
sql code with their ip address
we now only have to use
this ip address is in the
configuration of our application
we have reached the end of
the episode where we created
mice in a dish added
deranged fault role to
secure access to our application and
configure the connection to bass
and nerves through the private network
our application is now
accessible from the internet in a secure way
I hope you know found this
episode interesting thank you for your
attention  and see you soon
[Music]